hi walter
hi christina how's it going it's going
pretty well
hey that's swell congratulations on your
first disney plus series
oh my gosh thank you so much did you
know it's a triple first
it it's our first unscripted series it's
a first series first
uh streaming service and it's a it's a
first disney plus original
that is very cool the triple crown of
firsts why do you think now was the
right time to get into the streaming
business to do something unscripted
what made now the right time to make
muppets now
um let me ask you a question when
is it not the right time to make
something with the muppets
seriously and we've been waiting a while
for this you know
uh you know we the muppets now how about
the muppets always
that that's that's that's yeah oh
kindred spirit thank you i love that
what do you love most about being a
muppet
oh you know it's just it's it's it's
just where i fit
you know you know christina when you go
through your life it's really just
finding
finding the right place for you you know
i growing up i
i just i didn't know where i fit in
really you know i
couldn't find my tribe so to speak but
with these guys
with these guys right kermit souvenir
uh i just i just feel at home you know
it's like breathing
breathing since you're also clearly a
muppet fan what's it like to get to peek
behind the curtain and get to see not
only
how they all work but how different they
all are from each other
oh these guys are incredible i mean yeah
you know that has that actually has been
one of the most incredible things for me
is that
you know everybody knows everybody knows
like you know dr teeth for instance he's
really cool
rise mellow and laid back but i learned
that he's also a beekeeper
i i think it's learning these little
like extra details that just as a fan on
the outside you don't get really get to
see
that's that's been that's been kind of
most meaningful to me really getting to
know the
the heart of these fellas what do you
feel like you've learned from working
with kermit
and having his friendship oh wow
um humility um
i i've learned patience and i've learned
to stay the
heck out of miss piggy's way that sounds
like good advice
[ __ ] it's good advice for anyone and i
definitely learned that from kermit
in the show you learn how to photobomb
from kermit too who's clearly a master
at it so what clearly what impresses you
about his photo bombing skills and what
are the keys to pulling off a great
photo bomb well
that he can get away with it you know
he's so stealthy
i didn't know that about frogs but frogs
are stealthy they're quite stealthy
and slimy um but i think i think you
have to be able
it's something about the the timing of
it being able to you know sneak up on
somebody just be
in the background i it's it's not it's
not a gift i yet
possess but i'm working on it have you
gotten to
see your your human friends gary and
mary since
oh you know yeah not since you know
those guys got pretty busy
they did i think there were some academy
awards involved somewhere
did you did you know speaking of the
muppets that the 2011 film did you know
i won an academy award for man or muppet
did you know that
well you should well i did it won best
song that year
man or muppet of course they spelled my
name wrong they
they spelled it brett mckenzie well it's
a fantastic song so you should fully get
credit for that well thank you i
appreciate that
now that you've done this show for
disney plus what's what's the next step
in your career do you have plans and
dreams what what's the goal for walter
uh the goal for me well gee you know
what
just more just more more
more more muppets i i love these guys
and you know actually
we do have some things in development
like oh
yeah um joe from legal said i'm not
allowed to talk about
that stuff but but there's great things
coming but right now
there's great things now and that is
muppets
now which i will be watching
as soon as as this interview is over
i'll go back and watch some more
i can't i can't wait me too thanks
christie
i appreciate you talking to me thank you
sure bye